-And now we're going to get
to the news.
When asked last week
by reporters if he was confident
that he could get voting rights
legislation passed,
President Biden said,
"I hope we can get this done,
but I'm not sure."
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Quite a turn from the
"Yes we can" days.
It's like Nike
changing their slogan to,
"I don't know,
go for it if you want."
[ Laughter ]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
volunteered at a food bank
yesterday and wore a
Philadelphia Eagles T-shirt,
which was a nice way of showing
she understands pain
and hardship.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Donald Trump
held his first rally of the year
over the weekend in Arizona
and is already back
to telling lies.
-I love Arizona.
-Come on.
[ Laughter ]
The CDC is reportedly
experiencing a massive wave
of staff burnout,
and even that was reported
two weeks late.
[ Light laughter ]
Americans will be able
to order free
at-home rapid
coronavirus tests
from the federal government
this week
and an equally timely news
2020 New Year's glasses.
We like to get you the tests
after the wave.
Former President Trump
has reportedly been complaining
to confidants about Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
and said he has a,
"dull personality."
I'm sorry, that's suddenly
a concern of yours.
Your vice president was like
if a rice cake
went to Bible school.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Senator Mitt Romney
warned in a new interview
that Russian President
Vladimir Putin
is attempting to weaken
the NATO alliance
and recreate the Soviet Union.
Oh, thanks, Mitt.
[ Laughter ]
Mitt Romney's like a dad who
wanders in while you're watching
"Harry Potter" and says,
"that Voldemort fella
looks like bad news to me."
We know dad!
Get out!
DirecTV announced on Friday
that it will drop the
far right television
Channel One America News
from its service
once its current contract
expires
or sooner,
if it rains really hard.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, thought that was going to
be a joke about OAN,
but we went after DirecTV.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida Republican
who lost a congressional
special election last week
by 59 points is refusing
to concede the race,
but eventually he'll have
to go back to his old job
as Florida's math
teacher of the year.
[ Light laughter ]
Hopefully, people watching
this on DirecTV
got some really hard rain
before that joke.
[ Light laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new study,
playing a tape recording
of people's names
while sleeping can improve
name recall the next day,
so shout out to my writers
Ian, Bryan, and turn tape over.
[ Laughter ]
So there was a new study
about an old-timey tape player.
President Biden is reportedly
planning to communicate
more directly
with the American people
in an effort to increase
his poll numbers,
so you might want to switch
to the unlimited plan.
Uh-Huh. Yeah.
Build back better, right?
No. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. No, Amtrak's great.
Listen, I have to be like up
in like four hours.
House Democrats are reportedly
urging party leaders to abandon
President Biden's
build back better bill
and instead break up
the proposals
into a series
of smaller defeats.
[ Light laughter ]
The Senate today took up debate
on a House-passed
voting rights package that
combines the Freedom to Vote Act
and the John R. Lewis Voting
Rights Advancement Act.
Of course, it's already
dead in the water
thanks to can't act
and won't act.
In a new interview,
a political strategist,
James Carville, said
the Democrats should,
"Just quit being a whiny party
and get out there and fight
and tell people what you did."
Said Democrats, "Sounds hard."
[ Laughter ]
Former New York Mayor
Bill de Blasio announced today
that he will not
run for governor.
He then announced
something else,
but no one heard it over
the thunderous applause.
[ Laughter ]
A video gained attention online
over the weekend of Oklahoma
Pastor Mike Todd
spitting in his hand and rubbing
it onto his brother's eyes
during a sermon
which is weird for a pastor
but very on brand
for an older brother.
[ Laughter ]
Health officials
in Greece yesterday
imposed a vaccine mandate for
all citizens over 60 years old.
So if you're a 60-year-old
in Greece, you're Rizzo.
[ Laughter ]
I had a very depressing thing
just happen where,
you know, there was one person
enthusiastically liked it
and I'm like, "Well, at least
there's one audience member
here worth their salt."
[ Laughter ]
And then I turned around
and it was Amber.
It was it was our writer,
Amber Ruffin.
And now I'm starting to think
you didn't even laugh
at the joke.
I, knowing Amber, you were
laughing at how it went.
You're out of the Pink Ladies!
I would never do this stirring
the show,
but we're going to
we're going to stop it all down
and make everybody
watch "Grease."
[ Laughter ]
A man in South Dakota,
was arrested recently
after his mother served brownies
that he made with
marijuana butter at a senior
center,
caretakers became suspicious
when that night's
comedian got laughs.
[ Laughter ]
The FDA last week approved
the first treatment
to control arthritis
pain for cats.
It will replace
the old treatment
a brick in a burlap sack.
[ Laughter ]
Clear the palate.
[ Laughing ]
[ Normal voice ] And finally,
according to a new study,
men who live alone for years
are at a greater risk
of developing inflammation.
It's just a lot of stress
to put on one wrist.
[ Laughter ]
Makes you reassess
the dead cat joke, though.
Tomorrow will mark the end
of the first year
of President Biden's time
in office, so buddy,
you got like 24 hours
to make something happen.
You got to cancel student debt
or bring back "Lost"
or something.
I mean, even MSNBC
is struggling with headlines.
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
issued a subpoena yesterday
to Rudy Giuliani,
though really all you
have to do to make
Rudy appear is draw a pentagram
on the floor with Maalox.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
announced a plan today
to give Americans
hundreds of millions
of high quality
medical-grade face masks.
They're just doing that now.
What?
What are they sending out next,
sour dough starter?
That's right, the Biden
administration will distribute
hundreds of millions
of high-quality masks
through pharmacies like
Walgreens and CVS.
Unfortunately,
they're behind the razors
and the one guy with the key
is on lunch break.
[ Laughter ]
A White House official told CNN
that the distribution
of 400 million
free N95 masks next week is,
"The largest deployment
of personal protective equipment
in U.S. history."
Besides, of course,
the week that freshman
head off to college.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Louisiana Senate
candidate Gary Chambers
released a new campaign
ad yesterday
about legalizing marijuana
that appears to show him
smoking a blunt.
"He's got my vote," said people
who will forget to vote.
[ Laughter ]
Walmart is reportedly planning
to create its own NFTs,
and if you want a laugh, ask one
of their greeters about it.
I have no idea where that is.
Maybe transporting goods?
[ Laughter ]
The cost for an annual Citibank
membership in New York
will increase next week
by six dollars,
so to get their money's worth,
riders will have
to start throwing
an additional bike
into the Hudson every week.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
19% of adults
are participating in so-called
dry January,
which is what your girlfriend
experiences
when you show
her your Wordle score.
[ Laughter ]
You feel like 3%
better than we thought.
And finally, the Red Cross
will offer blood donors
a chance to win tickets
to the Super Bowl.
If they donate this month,
and for many donors,
this could be
their only chance to go.
President Biden yesterday held
a 1 hour and 51 minute
press conference.
It was the first thing
Americans actually wish
Joe Manchin had stopped.
[ Light laughter ]
During his press conference
yesterday,
President Biden said
Republicans were responsible
for some of his stalled agenda
and added,
"I, honest to God,
don't know what they're for."
Of course, that's the same thing
he said about AirPods.
[ Laughter ]
Today is the one-year
anniversary of President
Biden's inauguration,
and he's not going to like
Amanda Gorman's new poem.
"There once was a man named
Joe Biden
whose office
he usually cried in."
All right, that's enough.
President Biden said yesterday
that his first year in office
has been,
"A year of challenges."
But he'd rather focus on the
positives like your COVID test.
I can make it
because I've had it now.
[ Laughter ]
The Supreme Court voted
eight to one yesterday
in favor of releasing
former President Trump's
White House records
to the House Committee
investigating the January attack
on the Capitol eight to one.
This may be the first recorded
instance of Donald Trump
inspiring bipartisanship.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
said yesterday that House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi should be
banned from trading stocks,
which brings us
to a segment called,
"Dammit, I agree
with Trump."
♪♪
Man, there is nothing worse than
hearing a Trump opinion
and thinking
"The man's got a point."
But damn it,
I agree with Trump.
The only other time this
has happened was when he said
Ted Cruz might be
the Zodiac Killer.
Oh wait, I forgot.
Also, that press conference
where he said
McDonald's breakfast
should be all day.
This has been,
"Dammit, I Agree With Trump."
A British judge recently
ordered a neo-Nazi
convicted on terror --
convicted of terror charges
to read classic literature
as part of his sentence,
including Jane Austen's
"Pride and Prejudice,"
said the neo-Nazi, "Sweet,
my two favorite things."
Former President Trump --
they say "Sweet" a lot.
People don't know
that about neo-Nazis,
but they, you know,
they're like, "Sweet."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
is currently on a media tour
promoting his new photo book
"Our Journey Together," and he's
already being sued by iPhoto.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
a wildlife YouTerber,
a YouTuber on a trip to Thailand
recently discovered
a new species of tarantula
that lives inside
a bamboo plants.
Yikes. That is a terrifying
thought that that even exists.
A wildlife YouTuber, I mean.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪